neutral but prepared ready to defend
their nation that long relied on its own
military strength these finnish
conscripts are practicing an attack by
an imaginary
enemy but since the russian invasion of
ukraine finland which shares a board of
more than 1300 kilometers with russia
feels threatened by its large neighbor
obviously obviously it's shown that our
neighbors
willing to use force if necessary and
that changes things
before the war in ukraine only around 25
percent of finn supported joining nato
but this has now gone up to 76 percent a
dramatic change in a country that was
invaded by the soviet union in 1939 and
made an agreement to stay neutral after
the second world war ended thanks very
much putin you made it you made it so so
obviously we politicians we are living
in representative democracy we must
respect also the people's opinions
and that's where we are
the social democrat party mp was one of
finland's staunchest opponents of nato
membership not anymore it's a huge
turnaround for many in finland believing
for decades that staying neutral is key
to their security they know say that
putin's actions have pushed them towards
nato while russia has made it clear it's
not happy with this decision and that it
will react defense just hope it won't
retaliate
joining nato means finland will be
protected by its article 5 saying an
attack on one member is an attack on all
but it's the gray period of a number of
months before membership is formalized
that worries the finns
while the uk and other countries have
offered security guarantees the finnish
president is trying to reassure russia
in my thinking this is
quite
simple actually we increase our
security
and we do not take
it away from anybody i am
almost sure there will be no major
issues some political
et cetera et cetera that's true but
non-aggressive so i'm not actually
afraid because i still trust a little
bit that also in moscow they have brains
that's also what the young soldiers are
hoping for i think if
we were part of nato
then there would there would there would
be so much
uh
backup
so
no
i'm not
scared having a well-equipped army of
nearly 300 000 soldiers finland says it
will be an asset to nato while these
conscripts are looking forward to
working together with other nations
joining the alliance will put an end to
a long and peaceful period of neutrality
step faster al jazeera helsinki
[Music]